since you helped set up phone calls
between Donald Trump Putin and uh Kang
of Saud Arabia if I were to interview
Putin what advice would you
give on how
to get a deep understanding of the human
being yeah so I didn't deal with Russia
a ton but in my interaction with with
Putin and with Russia you know I I would
kind of point out a couple of things
number one is when America was hit with
coid and New York was looking like we
were going to run out of ventilators and
masks Russia was the second country that
sent us a plane load of supplies and
they didn't send that because they hate
America they sent that because we were
starting to make progress together as
countries and they thought that they
wanted to show Goodwill to figure out
how can we start working together and
again people may attack me for saying
that that sounds naive again the past
you know 15 years may show that that's
not the case but I don't believe that
countries have permanent enemies and I
don't believe countries have permanent
allies right again you think about the
US and Russia in World War II we work
together to to defeat the Nazis right
and now we're great allies with Germany
who basically was our great enemy in in
World War II we're great allies with
Japan who was our great enemy in World
War II so it goes back to the notion we
discussed earlier of you shouldn't
condemn tomorrow to be like yesterday if
you're unhappy with yesterday so um so
number one as I would definitely ask him
about that the phone call that you
mentioned was after we did a pretty
intense negotiation to create the
largest oil cut in the history of of oil
production so during coid demand just
shut off like crazy and it was it was
stopping very quickly uh Saudi and
Russia at that time were having a
conflict they created this thing called
OPEC plus uh which goes back again
history between the two countries where
um they had conflicts and then all of a
sudden they were working together to try
to stabilize the oil markets but they
couldn't agree on the cut so Saudi
actually increased inreased production
so you had two things hitting at once
where study and Russia were both
increasing production and demand was
dropping so you were headed for a real
crisis and I was starting to get calls
from a lot of the oil industry
Executives here in America saying you
don't understand we can't just like flip
a switch and turn off our oil wells like
we're running out of storage here and um
I said look president Trump likes low
oil prices so he's not upset about
what's happening you have to call him
and if he gives me permission or the
instruction then I can try to intervene
but uh but right now he's not inclined
to intervene after a little bit uh he
said you know what it's time get
involved go do it it was right over
Passover this was during coid I spent
three days non-stop on the phone with
Kel demitria from Russia and with uh
with NBS directly and I was dealing with
Dan Bret who was our energy Minister uh
you know going back and forth and it was
like it was crazy I mean it was just one
of the craziest negotiations we ended up
agreeing on the largest oil cut in the
history of the world but the story you
went to before which was pretty funny
was finally make the
deal and we set up a call between King
Salon uh Vladimir Putin and uh president
Trump to announce the deal I'm like oh
this is great this so president Trump
cans on congratulations we have a deal
and then King SM says we don't have a
deal uh Mexico hasn't agreed to their
Cuts he's say what do you mean and so
they were part of the OPEC plus and so I
get a note saying you got to go call
Mexico so I'm calling Mexico we're
dealing they're saying we're not doing
any Cuts said why I said we're hedged to
$55 said why didn't you tell us that in
the beginning so I'm telling the Saudis
are so we were working through this
whole thing so meanwhile we were trying
to find the compromise with Mexico I set
up a call with with Trump and Putin so
they can kind of talk this through and
he was always trying to play the game of
how do we get Russia away from China he
always thought that that was not the
right strategic framework for us
interests and again we had no problems
with them during that time what I would
say is that for zalinsky and Putin any
conversation with both of them is about
understanding their perspective I think
with Putin he's a a student of history
from the things that I I saw with him if
you look at Russia over the last 500
years I think they were attacked by the
Polish and in early 1600 I think they
were attacked by uh the swedes in in the
1700s I think they were attacked by
Napoleon in the 1800s and then in the
1900s they were attacked by Germany
twice and so from his perspect
perspective there is you know in the
early days of Russia uh they were
attacked by the Mongols they were very
vulnerable and a lot of the geography of
Russia Today is really designed for
defensive purposes that they have
natural barriers that makes them easier
to defend and Russia is a massive land
mass it's twice the size of America they
have 11 time zones in the country and so
I do think that for um for Vladimir
Putin his biggest concern is how do we
create a security Paradigm in the the
west of his country that won't be a
creep and I think that there's like two
different parts of the mindset you know
the people who are most cynical of Putin
will say well he's just trying to
recreate the USSR he's being
expansionist and the people who want to
be sympathetic to him will say well if
you think about it the Russian
perception of the NATO arrange
Arrangement was that they wouldn't be
expanding Westward over the last years
they've included all these countries
that they said they promised they
wouldn't include who knows what the
promises were or was were or weren't but
what I do know from his perspective is
allowing Ukraine and to Nato was always
a red line and that's why we never
offered it we never provoked it we never
brought it up we said we're going to arm
them and we basically said just just
calm down we don't want any conflicts
there we have bigger issues and bigger
opportunities to work for him so I do
think you have to think through what's a
paradigm that he can accept um and I do
think that you know he'll give the
justification for why he's done what
he's done and then I think the framework
for solution is about how do we move
both parties forward tough job I hope
you get the opportunity to do it because
I think it's a conversation that will
only help the world hopefully find a
pathway forward and I should mention
because you mentioned geography one of
the one of the many books you've
recommended to me that gives a very
interesting perspective on History it's
called prisoners of geography by Tim
Marshall and it has a very interesting
perspective on the
geopolitical conflicts and perspective
of Russia from a from a geography
perspective and um also for China in the
second chapter and there's a lot of
understanding of why the expansion of
NATO is such a concern for Russia
because geography still even in the 21st
century less and less so because of
technology and so on but it still plays
a major role in conflicts between
nations rivers mountains yeah and
understanding the DNA of countries it
was one of the most phenomenal books and
I I just found it on Amazon randomly but
I I loved every minute of it the chapter
on America is also incredible going
through the evolution of you know how we
became the country we are the different
Acquisitions the different changes why
we have all these Geographic advantages
and uh it's an unbelievable book for
anyone who's interested in
geopolitics
I